tiger - Player 01KA8RF0XJAXRM1ETS783XN19M:I am a Tiger.
transcript:1
tiger - Player 01KA8RF0V0G8WFY540EM7Y9R3W:I apparently
transcript:2
tiger - Player 01KA8RF0V0G8WFY540EM7Y9R3W:I'm also a tiger.
transcript:3
elephant - Player 01KA8RF0X7VFVR5W4NMWNPA5RV:Buy a elephant.
transcript:4
elephant - Player 01KA8RF0X7VFVR5W4NMWNPA5RV:This is a longer comment
transcript:5
elephant - Player 01KA8RF0X7VFVR5W4NMWNPA5RV:if I
transcript:6
elephant - Player 01KA8RF0X7VFVR5W4NMWNPA5RV:What is it mean?
transcript:7
elephant - Player 01KA8RF0X7VFVR5W4NMWNPA5RV:There's a light?
transcript:8
elephant - Player 01KA8RF0X7VFVR5W4NMWNPA5RV:And how long was
transcript:9
elephant - Player 01KA8RF0X7VFVR5W4NMWNPA5RV:landscape
transcript:10
elephant - Player 01KA8RF0X7VFVR5W4NMWNPA5RV:can I get the weird web talk?
transcript:11
elephant - Player 01KA8RF0X7VFVR5W4NMWNPA5RV:Tunnels, with
transcript:12
elephant - Player 01KA8RF0X7VFVR5W4NMWNPA5RV:Pay.